did rob what they took everything that's  funny  where are you going we're going to get  my dog and see anything  they stole my dog a delicacy in my  country right I never said you thought  it when I need your help John okay wear  extra Underpants why so we want the  dauber channel thing I want to play took  the dog the briefcase no Michael can you  find our gear dog back can address on  Google it all what are you doing  I gotta go steal back to drugs so I get  my dog back when I come something fun  could be dangerous maybe I'll die I've  got a boner for the first time in the  year  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  24 hours you probably don't care but um  you're saying 24 but your hands are  actually saying for you - no no there is  not wanna go to heaven tsunami know  [Music]  you